les vésicules sont comme les camions de
livraison de la cellule à l'intérieur de
ces immenses ac se trouve du cholestérol
ou d'une protéine qui viennent d'être
fabriqués vous avez des véhicules ici
des basques sont soudés et paul baysse
d'une machinerie lien spécifique alors
les pieds de cette machine marche sur
l'autoroute pour transporter les
véhicules de l'intérieur de la cellule
vers l'extérieur
la vésicule poursuit sa route avec cette
précieuse cargaison
lorsque la daisy qu arrive à l'enveloppé
externe
les deux membranes fusionnent lanvaux
voir la cargaison
le cargo qui est à à l'intérieur de
cette bestiole la cargaison sortir vers
l'extérieur libéré vers l'extérieur et
ces molécules sont des molécules très
importantes comme les hormones comme
insuline de ce que ne peut porter un
billet bien important pour nous